the hype is real big Marvel Studios
announcements and surprises for Disney
Plus hey Marvel is Ryan Pinocchio's aka
agent M here at d23 Expo 2019 now the
Disney Plus panel here was phenomenal
full announcements full of news full of
surprises and I was lucky enough to be
in the room with a few thousand of my
best friends but we had to ask my
friends like what are they excited about
what gets them hyped what news were they
really into let's find out what they had
to say I was just at the Disney Plus
panel and it was one of the most amazing
things I've ever seen in my life so I
was most excited to see Wanda vision and
they gave us a little glimpse of the
Flair kind of it's gonna what it's going
to be about seeing that that's when the
new Miss Marvel I'm excited for that
because the comic was great when it came
out but I'm also from the East Coast so
I'm waiting for that you know that
Jersey flavour being there also when
moon night when that was announced I was
freaking out there was a guy behind me
yelling at the top of his lungs he was
absolutely amazing I loved it I wanted
more Hulk in the MCU for so long and now
that we get she-hulk it's amazing you
guys can't make us choose that's way too
hard seeing what phase four has to
offers is amazing I can't wait what if
one division Loki I mean Falcon and
Winter Soldier honestly Kevin Feige and
the whole team can't do anything wrong
I'm just curious about who they're gonna
pick for each of those characters like
it was gonna be she hooked like that's
gonna be amazing or who's gonna be
Kamala Khan I honestly just want to know
what happened to Loki after he took the
tesseract I need to know if Wanda and
vision are gonna live in their little
apartment in Brooklyn the way that they
do in the comics when can I get the
Disney plus sooner so that I can start
watching like now otherwise no I'm good
where do I sign up over there I told
y'all the hype is real
very cool Disney Plus Marvel Studios
they came for it and they got it you
guys saw everybody's excited I'm Ryan
and this is Marvel your universe